VICTOR: Hi everyone.
I'm Victor.
Thanks for having us here.
Thanks to HTML5 for arranging
this wonderful meetup.
I work for Goo technologies,
based in Stockholm, Sweden.
And with me today,
as Peter said,
is another Peter, from Kaazing,
based here in California.
And as a colleague
of mine put it,
WebGL is very good at solving a
very specific computer science
problem of today.
And that problem is
to get the highest
amount of likes
per line of code.
The measurement to keep
track of the next few years
will be LPL, Likes Per Line.
And we've seen, as we've seen
in the previous talks, that
for example, Chrome
experiments, collecting
a lot of really cool hacks
of WebGL wizardry and WebGL
examples from people that
know this really well.
But the question now is how do
we get this into more hands?
How do we get WebGL into the
hands of all the creators
that are out there?
And this, of course,
can be graphics wizards
and game developers and hackers.
But it can also be artists,
architects, teachers,
advertisers, interface
designers, and so on.
How do we give them
the power of WebGL?
And the answer to that question
is, we build the pipelines,
and we design workflows.
Because not everyone
dreams about spending
all of their Friday nights
with shader debugging.
I know it's really hard to
imagine those people exist,
but they do.
So the first step, as
we've already seen,
also is to get a
3D engine going.
It takes care of all
the low level WebGL
stuff that we don't
want to do every time.
It gives us a nice
API to play with.
And one thing that I think is
very important when we do this,
is that we try to use open web
standards as much as possible.
In this case, it means
nothing but JavaScript HTML5
and of course, WebGL.
Because what happens then
is that, a lot of people
know JavaScript, and
suddenly they now
have tools to also know 3D.
And it also means that you don't
have any plug-ins and downloads
necessary to share
your work later.
I want to show you
some more demos.
So that's kind of why
we are here, right?
So this first demo can show
you that not only can you
render cool 3D stuff, you can
also integrate other things
in this, like,
for example, video
in this case, once you decide
to use all these open standards.
The other demo I want
to show is this one,
is something that
we've-- let's see.
So many sliders-- I need
more resolution, Peter.
Where's the resolution?
So now we see the slider,
and I can click that one,
sorry about that.
There we go.
This is a demo of pretty much
a full-fledged flight simulator
of a really old
Swedish fighter plane.
Those exist, actually.
It's a thing.
I did not make that up.
This screencast is
recorded in Chrome,
and it's something that we
have developed internally
while we are building
our Goo engine.
Because it turns out it's
not easy to build a pipeline,
and it's really hard
to define a workflow,
and you need people to tell you
how they want it to be done.
So this is what can
be done of course,
and it's really useful
to have people in-house
to do that kind of stuff.
So that's great.
Now we have a couple
of different 3D engines
in the open web standards
that we can use.
But what do we do about the
people that don't want to code,
or don't know how to code?
Well the answer is again,
we build a pipeline.
We build more things.
We build a pipeline
that can handle things.
So if you have a model of a
really old Swedish fighter
plane, and you want
to get this online,
you need a way to do that.
And you need a way
to do things visually
without necessarily
writing code all the time
to move things around.
And then, of course,
you want to be
able to share it with as
many users as possible,
to get as many
likes as possible.
That's the whole point.
So I'd like to show
you a tool that
does try to solve
part of this puzzle.
And this tool will
be called Goo Create.
It looks like this.
And this part here to the
right is the 3D canvas,
where the 3D engine will put
all the stuff and render that.
The interface that you
can see to the left
here is built using a very,
very, very large amount
of Angular.
And behind all of this, there's
a Python back-end running.
And the back-end takes care
of exporting and importing
models into a format that
the engine understands,
but it also fills the
very important part
of managing users and projects.
Because in a
pipeline, of course,
you want a place
to do your things,
you want one place to
store all your work.
So the way this works
is, say that you
have a 3D model
that someone built.
In this case,
saved in a COLLADA,
a large FBX file format.
And what you can do
here is you simply,
if we can get all the windows
to see at the same time,
you can drag and drop
this onto the canvas,
and once the back-end has
converted this to a format
that the engine understands, we
can start to interact with it.
So there we go.
Now we have this 3D
model here, and I
can start interacting with it.
It looks kind of
creepy right now,
but luckily the
designers thought of that
and put some materials
and textures onto this.
So clothing, for example,
what we can do here now
is do some more
dragging and dropping,
because I happen to have
textures in the standard PNG
format here.
So this was the clothing.
So let's just do this so you
can see what happens here.
Drag and drop that
onto the model,
and then we can do the
same thing for the hair,
and for the skin, as well.
There we go.
And that looks a
little better, right?
And this interface lets
us interact with it
and add things like sounds and
cameras and lights and so on.
And this model happens
to have an animation,
so if I press play here,
we can watch it and see it
in real time without
writing any code.
So let's try to add light, for
example, and see what happens.
Add light here, and we can
start moving that around,
set some parameters, and see
the scene change in real time,
fully interactively.
It's all in the browser.
It's not using any plug-ins
or any downloads like that.
And let's go to
my favorite panel,
and it's the post effects panel.
It's very good for likes,
very good for likes.
So if we want to add some glow
to this-- that's a bit much.
Maybe tone down a little
bit-- or some grain,
we can add some movie
vignetting, et cetera,
et cetera.
You get the point.
And once we're
done with the scene
now, thanks to that we
have all these awesome web
standards to play with, we
can share our work very easily
by just a basic
clicking a button,
bundling everything
up together, including
the engine and the data format,
and push this to our website.
And now if you have a decent
WebGL compatible browser
on your tablet or your
phone or your computer,
on your refrigerator or
your washing machine,
insert into this web site.
And look at this
right now, actually.
I'll give you a TinyURL
version of this in a minute.
And of course, if you want to
code, you can do that as well.
You can export this into
a JavaScript template,
and add to your own
code and then keep
working on that, because
we like to code, right?
Now, if you want to try
this out, you can do that.
You can go to that TinyURL,
and you'll see the same link.
Or you can sign up
for the beta, it's
free right now if you
want to try the tool out.
So what happens now?
What's next?
We have all these things.
I can take my Swedish
fighter jet model
and put it on the
internet, but we
need to think about what
happens in the future.
And I want to talk a little
bit about the funnel.
It's a kind of pipeline, right?
You take a lot of input, and
you get a very defined output.
So here's my invention,
it's the double funnel.
Probably the worst
invention ever made,
if you would ever
use it in real life.
It's really hard to get
venture capital for it,
but if you want to talk
later, we can do that.
But it illustrates
the point here.
We want to take a wide array
of inputs from different people
in different formats
for different purposes,
use the tools that we
have, and then push it out
to different distribution
channels, cooperation ways.
We want to push these
to different games,
to apps, to programs,
whatever, you name it.
So the double funnel.
It's the future, promise.
Demo time again, of course.
We like demos.
I want to show you a little
bit more complete product built
on this Goo engine.
This is the same guy
that we saw earlier.
And this one, I can
make him row around here
by pressing the standard
keyboard control.
I can turn him
around, and so forth.
It's all done
interactively in real time.
And a mouse and a
keyboard is fine,
but if we want to kick it up a
few notches, Peter, what do we
do then?
PETER: That's excellent, great.
Thank you, Victor.
This is awesome.
So what we've seen is that
you can add extra layers
and tooling on top of
WebGL, and by doing so,
you can make it
accessible to those
who are not necessarily coding.
So what I wanted to
discuss a little bit
is how we can use related
HTML5 technologies
to improve the WebGL experience.
Specifically, the area
that we are focusing on,
and I've been focusing on
in the last couple of years
is real time web
communications, and how
you can improve this experience.
So what I've done
here is I pulled up
a remote control on my browser.
The remote control on my
phone is running in Safari
without having
installed anything.
I have a URL that I went to.
And by simply tapping the
buttons here on my phone,
I am sending messages to
the application that's
running here on the desktop.
So what is happening
here behind the scenes,
my phone is on the
AT&T LTE network,
and it has a means to send
a very low latency, very
small messages, to
my PC over here.
So let's take a very
quick look at how
we can achieve this
kind of experience.
Let me do a little bit
of [INAUDIBLE] here.
So I have my desktop
app pulled up
that is a web browser on
the top, and on the bottom,
we see my Safari browser.
Both of these HTML5
apps are connecting
to a WebSocket server.
The WebSocket server
has the ability
to receive and send messages.
So very much-- thank you-- very
much like in the world of HTTP,
you do need a WebSocket server
for WebSocket communication.
The fundamental difference
between the REST-based world,
and the WebSocket-based
world, is
that you have the
ability to keep
this connection open between
your client and the server,
and send these messages
with extremely low overhead,
back and forth
between the server.
So my desktop application is
not sitting there and polling
the server, is there
a new message for me?
Is there a new message for me?
It's just sitting there idle.
And whenever I press a
button here on my phone,
the WebSocket server passes
that message to the application
and-- let me close
this-- and it allows
us to navigate on the screen.
So a few words about this
communication technique.
Originally, it was designed
to bring the same power
to web applications that
we have in the world
of any connected application
in the TCP world.
So now you can say that
whatever app there is out there,
whatever connected app is out
there in the world of TCP, now
we can do that over the web.
And this gives us
an incredible power
to improve our WebGL and
non-WebGL applications.
So we have this
permanent connection,
and that allows us to
build these events driven
applications, which is a
major shift from having
REST-oriented request
response kind of applications,
where the client is requesting
information from the server.
Now you have the ability to
send these messages freely back
and forth.
When you're building
a network application,
you are not going against
a low-level network
API or a protocol.
If you are building an
email application or chat
application, there's
a good chance
that you're using something
like IMAP or SMTP for email
or XMPP Java for
your email client.
WebSocket, as the
standard was designed
to support these higher
level, richer protocols.
So in our case, you can build
very easy pub/sub experiences,
pub/sub APIs, that allow
you to build these apps very
quickly and very easily.
Not only that, WebSocket
was not designed
to be there exclusively
for web browsers.
It was designed to be
agnostic to the client.
So you can build native
mobile applications,
you can build Android and
iOS applications, natively.
Not only that, you can
build desktop applications.
You can have a dot.net, a flash,
or a Java application that
can have this kind of real
time communication going
all over the web.
So again, remember,
I had a browser
based app running
here on my phone.
I was connecting to
the network over LTE.
I press the button
here, and that message
was sent to the
WebSocket server,
and it bounced back
here to my laptop.
That WebSocket server that
I was communicating with
is in the east coast of the
US, 3,000 miles away from here.
So it had to cross the
continent back and forth
to get this data here across.
OK.
Now I wanted to show
an example of how
this can be elevated
even further.
Everybody brought their
awesome 3D designs,
and awesome 3D models, and
I decided to bring mine.
So here I have my 3D model.
Just look at the textures here.
Look at the reflections
on the design.
It's pretty impressive.
So what is this?
We went out to Toys
R Us, and we bought
a radio-controlled truck.
And after driving it around
a little bit in the office,
we said that maybe
we can do it better.
So we ripped out all the
radio control functionality,
and we glued a credit
card sized little computer
onto the back of the truck.
And what this does,
is it has USB ports.
You can attach a
little WiFi card.
It has an ethernet port.
It has an SD card that you can
put the operating system on.
But most importantly,
it has the ability
to control external electronics.
It has a notion of a
general purpose input/output
port that allows you to
control, let's say, a car.
You can drive it
around, in our case.
We have three pairs
of these adapters,
and I'm going to attempt to
show that to you in a minute.
Now I could drive it
around the same way
I was controlling the
leap boy on the screen,
or the Pearl Boy on the screen.
But my favorite way of showing
this kind of demonstration
is having somebody very far
away, maybe continents away,
Skyped in, and have that
person control the truck.
Now we have some network
limitations here,
and we couldn't achieve this,
or couldn't quite do this,
to set up this networking.
But I brought the
experience to you.
So I'm kind of doing
these acrobatic tricks
without the net underneath me.
So we'll try to do this.
So what is going to happen
is I will bring up a page,
and in this page we are
going to do a video call.
So in the top left
corner, you see me.
And in the middle of the
screen, you see David.
And David has this ability of
sitting there very patiently
and not moving at
all while he is
waiting to control the truck.
So let's see if we can
have a chat with David.
Hey, David, can you hear us?
DAVID: Hello, can you hear me?
PETER: Yeah, we can hear you.
Hey are you online?
DAVID: Well yeah, we are
on a video call right now,
so I think I'm online.
PETER: Yeah, that's
a good point.
Hey, we have a truck
here that we could use.
DAVID: A truck?
PETER: Yeah, a truck.
DAVID: I thought we were going
to be controlling a drone.
PETER: No, we had to
cancel the drone project.
DAVID: Oh, OK.
PETER: Can you help
us with the truck?
DAVID: Yeah, absolutely.
PETER: OK, so what
are you going to do?
DAVID: So I have the
controls pulled up over here
on my phone.
PETER: OK.
DAVID: So if you hold up
the truck on your end,
I can actually turn
on and off the lights.
So, on, off, on, off,
PETER: Very cool.
Can you turn the front
wheels left and right?
DAVID: Yeah, absolutely.
Right, left, right, left.
PETER: Very cool.
Can you spin the
wheels a little bit?
DAVID: Yeah, so, forward,
reverse, and forward, reverse.
PETER: Very cool.
I'm going to put it
down on the floor.
Can you control it there
a little bit for us?
DAVID: Sure.
Let me know when you're ready.
PETER: OK, we are ready.
But be gentle!
Very cool!
Awesome!
Thank you, David.
DAVID: Oh, you're welcome.
PETER: Very nice.
DAVID: So next time,
remember to bring the drone.
PETER: We will
bring to the drone
for you, don't worry about that.
DAVID: Bye.
PETER: OK, take care.
So-- [APPLAUSE] thank you.
So what you have seen is magic.
Basically what we did
was we have a web browser
running on a mobile
device that can
be on a carrier's network,
that has the ability
to send real time messages
to any web application
out there, or any WebSocket
client, for that matter.
In our case, its Java code
running on the Raspberry Pi.
If you're interested in how
this experience was created here
for you, can just Google here
in the bottom right corner.
You Google for
WebSocket and Popcorn.
Popcorn is an awesome
media library,
and you can do these
nice experiences with it.
There's a blog post
that was just put out.
You can read all the details.
Now, what do I do
when I am not here
and having fun and meeting
nice people at meetups?
There are many, many
challenges in the real time web
communication space that make
it really hard and challenging
to build and provide
seamless experiences.
There's a notion of
firewalls and routers,
your connection gets broken down
because you are in a tunnel,
maybe you need to scale
up to millions of users
because you've become
very successful suddenly.
These are the kinds of problems
that we are trying to solve,
and we are very busy
solving at Kaazing.
So if you want to learn more
about Goo, how Goo enables
web developers as well
as creative people,
here are a handful of links
for you that you can go.
Goo is having a beta
program, and you're
encouraged to sign up to those.
And if you're interested in any
of the real time communication
aspects, how you can
bring this kind of power
to your WebGL apps, as well
as to the physical world,
you can visit the links
on the Kaazing site.
And last, here's the
contact information for us.
Thank you very much.
VICTOR: Great!
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]